salut à vous peuple d internet enfin on
se retrouve d'une manière un petit peu
intime sur cette chaîne juste vous et
moi
avant de commencer à parler de ses 25
émotions cachées vous aurez remarqué de
choses déjà c'est pas ma caméra parce
que la mienne vient de se casser ce
matin l'alegria oui celle qui ne se fait
plus qui ne se vend plus je suis très
heureux j'ai donc emprunté celle ci pour
aujourd'hui je vois comment je vais
faire pour la suite mais tous les
changements que vous voyez au niveau de
la lumière ça c'est autre chose
j'aime faire récemment une vidéo avec la
chaîne de vini vidi fidme ou bruno a
pris le temps de me coacher sur la
lumière de m'apprendre à utiliser des
lumières avec un petit budget le lien de
cette vidéo sera dans la description si
vous voulez en voir plus je vous
recommande
parce que je suis en train de comprendre
plein de choses et ça va être cool pour
l'évolution de cette chaîne mais c'est
parfait s'il oeuvrait en profiter pour
faire des travaux nous sommes très
heureux de ça et également quelques
secondes avant de commencer je vous
rappelle que les ventes pour les billets
de l'olympia sont en classe je viens de
filmer un spectacle autre jour je
pouvoir vous faire voir un petit peu ce
qu'il ya dans ce spectacle
en tout cas c'est un projet commun entre
vous et moi donc n'hésitez pas à
réserver ou à prendre des places pour
noël plus en plus de sélectionner les
meilleures places pour le spectacle ça
permet en même temps moi d'imaginer des
choses plus conséquente en fonction du
nombre de personnes cazères et à chaque
réservation de place justement jeu je
vis une émotion particulière mais
parfois quand on vit des émotions comme
la joie par exemple comme dans la
dernière vidéo les émotions qu'on
s'amusait à jouer avec super connard et
sylvine h
on peut trouver que le mot qui est su de
cette émotion en elle-même et limitant
et autant ces pratiques dans les
micro-expressions d'avoir une émotion
brute et une espèce de cases dans
lesquelles on peut les ranger est donc
détectée
autant on aimerait avoir une palette de
mots un peu plus complexe pour définir
une émotion particulière
eh bien c'est exactement ce qui s'est
dit l'écrivain john fanning dans son
mr des chagrins losc
faut arrêter les trains vous faut aller
manger un moment donné je suis désolé
par le bruit est obligé de faire cette
vidéo maintenant sinon elle pourra pas
sortir vendredi
ce que j'étais en train de vous dire
l'écrivain john koning qui a écrit le
dictionnaire des chagrins obscur s'est
posé le même constat et la même question
et il a à ce titre créé des mots pour
des émotions particulières qui existent
mais qui ne peuvent pas être nominatives
j'ai trouvé ça hyper intéressant de vous
en parler parce qu'en plus je trouve que
les mots correspondre un petit peu à
cette réalité là par exemple comme
sentiments il a inventé l'anecdote
l'anecdote l'anecdote pour lui c'est ce
que tu ressens dans une conversation où
tout le monde parle et personne
s'écoutent un sentiment d'anecdotes
j'aime bien l'idée c'est moi j'aime bien
ce mot je vais vous en donner comme ça
une petite quinzaine une élite sim
c'est le sentiment que l'on ressent le
sentiment de tristesse qu'on se rend
compte qu'on ne connaîtra jamais la fin
d'une histoire
les anonymes c'est le sentiment que tout
va de plus en plus vite l'exil en dix
ans n'a pas un peu l'impression d'être
dans harry potter alors l'exil en dise
c'est le sentiment d'essayer de prendre
fin une conversation de fermer une
conversation de la terminer parce que
personne ne comprend ce que vous êtes en
train de dire ce qui peut être
exactement ce qui est en train de se
passer
là entre nous le chrysalis mhz alors le
chrysalis mme j'aime bien ce mot parce
que j'aime bien le sentiment qu'il
décrit c'est le sentiment que tu as
quand tu es chez toi dans ta maison
alors que dehors il pleut énormément il
tombe des cordes ya de l'orage où il
neige
enfin où il faut être vraiment un temps
dégueulasse mais que toi tu es
tranquille en sécurité au sec et au
chaud dans ta maison l'aunis mme rien à
voir avec le nanisme c'est pas du tout
pareil
le nice mais c'est un sentiment de
frustration d'être coincé dans un corps
dans un lieu en faisant qu'une seule
chose à la fois c'est le sentiment comme
ça restrictif qu'on ressent lionisme le
rubato this rien à voir avec une maladie
non le rubato this c'est le sentiment
quand on vient de prendre conscience de
chaque battement de son coeur vous savez
qu'on l'entend qu'on le ressent on et
focus dessus qu'on se rend compte que ça
fonctionne je veux un petit bateau si ce
que tu ressens en ce moment là le velly
shore alors le velly shore c'est un
sentiment a priori non définie
mais c'est la chose que l'on ressent
quand on voit des vieux livres usées il
a mis un nom sur ce sentiment là le
velly shirt je trouvais ça très
intéressant de voir quelqu'un qui avec
son imagination a mis des mots sur des
sentiments qu'on n'avait pas déterminé
forcément qu'ils sont plus des
sensations mêlés à des émotions et
parfois qu'on met un mot sur un
sentiment ou sur une pensée particulière
ça prend sens différemment je vous mets
un lien vers son livre dans la
description je vous mets aussi un lien
vers une conférence ted qu'il avait fait
et qui est très inspirante et moi il ya
quelques temps de ça quelques moi même
j'avais fait une vidéo en fait sur
l'impact du mot sur la pensée c'est si
on change un mot par un autre c'est
utilisé par exemple en communication et
en politique alors la pensée et
construite différemment je vous mets un
lien vers cette vidéo si vous l'avez pas
vu je vous la recommande dans les
commentaires vous pouvez l'imaginer vous
aussi à mots correspondre à une émotion
fait le vraiment joué le jeu j'essaierai
d'en trouver un aussi je mettrais moi
aussi un truc ou deux comme ça dans les
commentaires de d'émotion que je serai
capable d'inventer dont vous prenez une
situation vous analysez l'émotion vous
ressentez et vous mettez un nom à sa
voulu donner un nom et vous mettez dans
les commentaires n'oubliez pas de
cliquer ci s'est pas encore fait de vous
abonner à la chaîne évidemment parce que
le mental blog ses vidéos par jour
pendant un an
mais ça c'était l'année dernière donc à
mardi alors si c'est pas encore fait tu
peux aussi s'abonner à la chaîne
simplement en cliquant sur le petit rond
que tu vois voilà juste ici c'est ce
petit rond là ça marche depuis la
tablette le téléphone c'est extrêmement
pratique il n'y a plus de raison
d'attendre
allez-y abonnez vous c'est cool